the Joe Rogan experience did you I'm
sure you've talked about this a million
times did you did you ever stop going
there for a chunk of time are you I
stopped for seven years
oh yeah I stopped for seven years after
I had that dispute with Carlos Mencia
yeah that was when he was way more
popular than me like especially as a
comic and the comedy star took his side
and I was like oh [ __ ] you guys and I I
took off it wasn't really the Comedy
Store either it was this one guy was the
manager cuz Mitzi actually I called
Mitzi and gave her the whole rundown of
what was going on I told her and she's
like why I just stay away from them and
then she gave me a spot that night and
then they called me up two hours later
tell me that I was banned
so I said wait a minute I just talked to
Mitzi like she gave me a spot she told
me when to go up so if if she's not
running the store guess who's deciding
I'm banned you are like what are you
doing like do you guys understand what
this is I mean this is like a little
you're having a little battle for like
whether or not you're going to let
people profit off of crime like this is
really what's happening you have
thoughtcrime
you have intellectual crime you're
plagiarism and you're allowing one
person you're knowingly allowing them to
profit off it and no one's doing
anything about it so when one of us does
something about it then you're going to
punish that person you're basically
highlighting everything that everyone
was afraid of that's a good point what
is like what were the what was the
reason for your being banned because you
were well because their end of it I
think was because we had made a video
with me and Carlos arguing on stage and
then we put it all right
okay this was you know somehow another
in violation that should have been kept
inside the club and I'm like you don't
get it you weren't protecting us no-one
was protecting us my [ __ ] agents
dumped me over that oh yeah over that
yeah I was with Gerst they dropped me
holy we had that call me up to tell me
they essentially in this long roundabout
way we're trying to say that I either
had to apologize or they couldn't work
with him anymore
though that was the gist of it and I had
to make them spell it out okay
let me say this really clear you tell me
if this is what you're saying you're
saying you want me to apologize or you
can't work with me anymore well we're
done you know there's no apology and
we're never gonna work together I
appreciate everything you've done for me
and I was really nice to the guy who was
it wasn't his idea
my agent so you're a great guy I see you
I'm giving you a hug but you guys have
to understand that you're making a
choice it's gonna affect the rest of
your life this isn't just a small thing
you only have a few how many years you
have in this life well this year is
going to be highlighted by this decision
this is gonna be a why did you why did
the agent take that stand did they
represent him as a yes okay all right so
they needed to make nice what they've
made way more money than me so it was
what he was way more valuable to them
and so I'm like you gotta make this is
you sell art that's all you guys do okay
you're not making anything right you
just if Mary Lynn comes up with the show
if this guy has a tour if she's doing of
this or he's writing a book you make
money off art that's who you make money
off now here you know a guy's stealing
other people's art and your answer to
that is we gotta stop people that are
exposing it did he ever change that I
hope he did just gotta find Jesus did it
sort of yeah sort of and then he kind of
took it back it's hard to admit
[Applause]